who is your favorite robot in science
fiction books or movies
wall-e and r2d2 where they were able to
convey such an incredible degree of
intent emotion and kind of character
attachment without
having any language whatsoever um and
just purely through the emotion richness
of emotional interaction so those were
fantastic and then uh
the terminator series just like really
really okay pretty
i kind of love this uh dynamic where you
have this like incredible terminator
itself that arnold played but uh and
then he was kind of like the inferior
like previous generation version that
was like totally outmatched
you know in terms of kind of specs by
the new one but you know still kind of
like held his own and so it was kind of
interesting where you you realize how
many how many levels there are on the
spectrum from human to kind of
potentials and ai and robotics to uh
futures and so yeah that movie really uh
as much as it was like kind of a dark
world in a way was actually quite
fascinating gets the imagination going
well from an engineering perspective
both the movies you mentioned wally and
terminator the first one
is probably achievable you know humanoid
robot
maybe not with like the realism in terms
of skin and so on but that humanoid form
we have that humanoid form it seems like
a compelling form maybe the challenge is
just super expensive to enjoy to build
but you can imagine maybe not a machine
of war but you could imagine terminator
type robots walking around yeah and then
the same obviously with wall-e you've
basically so for people who don't know
you uh created the company anki that
created a small robot with a big
personality called coswell that just it
does exactly what wally does which is
somehow with
very few basic
visual tools is able to communicate a
depth of emotion and that's fascinating
but then again the humanoid form is
uh super compelling so like cosmo is
very distant from a humanoid form and
then the terminator has a humanoid for
me you can imagine both of those
actually being in our society it's true
and it's interesting because um it was
very intentional to go really far away
from human form when you think about a
character like cosmo or like wall-e
where um
you can completely rethink uh the
constraints you put on that character um
what tools you leverage and then how you
actually create a personality uh and uh
level of intelligence interactivity that
actually
matches the constraints that you're
under whether it's mechanical or sensors
or ai of the day this is why i almost
was always really surprised by how much
energy people put towards trying to
replicate human form in a robot because
you actually take on some pretty
significant um kind of constraints and
downsides when you do that um the first
of which is obviously the cost where
it's just the the articulation of a
human body is just so
like magical um in both the precision as
well as the dimensionality that to
replicate that even in this quote
reasonably close form takes like a giant
amount of joints and actuators and uh in
motion and
you know sensors and encoders and so
forth but then um you're almost like
setting an expectation that the closer
you try to get to human form the more
you expect the strengths to match
and that's not the way ai works is
there's places where you're way stronger
and there's places where you're weaker
and by moving away from human form you
can actually uh change the rules and
embrace your strengths and bypass your
weaknesses and at the same time the
human form
like has way too many degrees of freedom
to play with it's it's kind of
counterintuitive just as you're saying
but when you have fewer constraints
it's almost harder to master the the
communication of emotion like you see
this with cartoons like stick figures
you can communicate quite a lot with
just
very minimal like two dots for eyes and
a line for for a smile i think like you
can almost communicate arbitrary levels
of emotion with just two dots and a line
yeah and like that's enough and if you
focus on just that
you can communicate the full range and
then you like if you do that then you
can focus on the actual magic
of of uh
human and
dot line interaction versus all the
engineering mess that's right like
dimensionality voice all these sort of
things they actually become a crutch
where you get lost in a search space
almost um
and so some of the best animators that
we've worked with um they almost like
study when they come up uh you know kind
of in building their expertise by
forcing these um projects where all you
have is like a ball that can like kind
of jump and manipulate itself or like
really really like aggressive
constraints where you're forced to kind
of
extract the deepest level of motion and
so in a lot of ways um you know we
thought when we thought about cosmos
like you're right like our if we had to
like describe it in like one small
phrase it was bringing a pixar character
to life in the real world it's uh it's
what we were going for and um in a lot
of ways what was interesting is that
with like wall-e which we studied
incredibly deeply and in fact some of
our team were you know kind of had
worked previously at um at pixar on that
project
they intentionally constrained wall-e as
well even though in an animated film you
could do whatever you wanted to because
it forced you to like
really saturate the smaller amount of
dimensions but uh you sometimes end up
getting a far more beautiful output um
because you're pushing at the extremes
um
of this emotional space in a way that
you just wouldn't because you get lost
in a surface area uh if you have like
something that is just infinitely
articulable so if we backtrack a little
bit and uh you thought of cosmo in 2011
and 2013 actually uh designed and built
it what is anki what is cosmo
i guess who is cosmo and uh
uh what was the vision behind this
incredible little robot we started uh
anki back in
like while we were still in graduate
school so myself and my two co-founders
we were phd students uh
in the robotics institute at carnegie
mellon um and so we were uh studying
robotics ai machine learning kind of
different you know different uh
areas one of my co-founders working on
walking robots you know for a period of
time and so we all had a um a bit of a
really deep kind of a deeper passion for
applications of robotics and ai where um
there's like a spectrum where there's
people that get like really fascinated
by the theory of ai and machine learning
robotics where um whether it gets
applied in the near future or not is
less of a kind of factor on them but
they love the pursuit of like the
challenge and that's necessary and
there's a lot of incredible
breakthroughs that happen there we're
probably closer to the other end of the
spectrum where we love the technology
and the um and all the evolution of it
but we were really driven by
applications like how can you really
reinvent experiences and functionality
and build value that wouldn't have been
possible without these approaches and
and that's what drove us and we had a
kind of some experiences through
previous jobs and internships where we
like got to see the applied side of
robotics and at that time there's
actually relatively few applications of
robotics um that were outside of um
you know pure research or industrial
applications um military applications
and so forth there were very few outside
of it so maybe you know by robot was
like one exception and maybe there are a
few others but for the most part there
weren't that many and so we got excited
about consumer applications of robotics
where you could leverage
way higher levels of intelligence
through software to create value and
experiences that were just not possible
in
in those fields today
and we saw
kind of a pretty wide range of
applications um that varied in the
complexity of what it would take to
actually solve those and what we wanted
to do was to commercialize this into a
company but actually
do a bottoms-up approach where we could
have a huge impact in a space that was
ripe to have an impact at that time and
then build up off of that and move into
other areas and entertainment became the
place to start because um you had
relatively little innovation in the toy
space
and entertainment space you had these
really rich
experiences in video games and uh and
movies but there was like this chasm in
between and so we thought that
we could really reinvent that experience
and there was a
a really fascinating transition
technically that was happening at the
time where the cost of components was
plummeting because of the mobile phone
industry and then the smartphone
industry and so the cost of a
microcontroller of a camera of a motor
of memory of
microphones cameras was dropping by
orders of magnitude and then on top of
that with the iphone coming out in 2000
uh i think it was 2007 i believe
um
it started to become apparent within a
couple of years that this could become a
really incredible
interface device and the brain with much
more computation behind a physical world
experience that wouldn't have been
possible previously um and so
um we really got excited about that and
how we push all the complexity from the
physical world into software by using
really inexpensive components but
putting huge amounts of complexity into
the ai side and so cosmo became our
second product and then the one that
we're probably most proud of the idea
there was to create a physical character
that had enough understanding and
awareness of the physical world around
it and the context that mattered to feel
like
uh like he was alive um and uh to be
able to have these like emotional kind
connections and experiences with people
that you would typically only find
inside of a movie and the motivation
very much was was pixar like we had an
incredible uh respect and appreciation
for what they were able to um build in
this like really beautiful fashion and
film um but it was always like a you
know when it was virtual and two it was
like a story on rails that had no
interactivity to it
you